[Applause]
starwars the last Jedi was directed by
Rian Johnson and stars a whole bunch of
people and porks and it's about Rafe in
Poe Luke Leia kylo and a whole bunch of
Star Wars folk on a big adventure and
that's all I'm gonna say you should just
go see it I'm not saying anything else
joking aside if you saw the force
awakens you know that it quite literally
ended with a cliffhanger Rey extending
that lightsaber out to Luke and us
wondering what he's gonna do with it
this film answers that question and a
lot of other questions and has a lot of
fun doing it and I had a blast watching
the last Jedi this is a really really
damn entertaining Star Wars movie and
one with a unique voice Brian Johnson is
able to direct this film and please I'm
sure the vast majority of Star Wars fans
but his voice is not lost in the shuffle
I've seen all of his films I've been a
fan of his ever since brick that was one
of the very first movies on my channel
that I gave an A+ to my highest rating
the vision that he has shown in films
like brick and looper and even the
Brothers Bloom is very much so present
here he has a great knack for filming
terrific action sequences and his voice
and his humor are ever-present in this
film it's a very funny movie just like
the force awakens was a lot of great
jokes and none of them feel like they're
at the expense of the characters it
doesn't feel like they're referencing
things either just to reference them
sure there are winks and nods and
references but to ask the eighth film in
a saga to act like the others didn't
even exist I think is unfair but the
fanservice in the last Jedi does not
come at an expense to the story it
doesn't feel like a throwaway moment
like in rogue one where we saw at c-3po
just going oh yes I'm in this movie
because I'm in every Star Wars movie and
we couldn't have it not be in this it
doesn't feel like the fanservice
in the last Jedi is there because oh
yeah I remember that Star Wars thing
Johnson's love for Star Wars and for
these characters shines through but also
ways that he questions certain things
that have
become established in star wars I'll
talk more about this in my spoiler
review but the film does bring up things
about previous Star Wars stories and
asks questions that I think people
walking into this universe like our new
characters would logically want to know
about and the film has a surprising way
of exploring these questions let's talk
a little bit about the performances
Daisy Ridley once again is proving to be
an excellent choice as Rey she's
terrific in the action sequences and the
dramatic stuff she's an incredible
actress John boyega once again amazing
his fin oh boy let's talk about Carrie
Fisher this was tough this was really
hard for me actually because she was
kind of a childhood hero of mine and of
course when she passed away this was one
of the the real celebrity deaths that
actually kind of affected me and it was
it was tough seeing her in this film but
I think they did a great job with her
character and it has some truly
satisfying moments and it was just it
was really nice to see her on screen and
she was great in this movie Mark Hamill
is the best he has ever been has Luke
Skywalker and this is easily his best
performance he is magnificent in this
film every single scene with him was
awesome he was really really good this
is a character as I said dealing with
quite a bit obviously he has secluded
himself on this island and so some
history has led to that and the
exploration of that in this film was
wonderful Hamill you really knocked it
out of the park you gave me everything I
wanted in a Luke Skywalker and
everything I didn't know I wanted I'm
sure has a lot of you know he has said
that he was kind of surprised by the
direction Rian Johnson took and I can
see why and it definitely paid off I
think this is a very unique vision and
that's what I'll say for now until the
spoiler review this is definitely
definitely different when it comes to
his character
Johnson has also done something with the
action sequences in particular anything
involving a lightsaber that I have
wanted for ever my favorite shots
any lightsaber battles are always the
head-to-toe wides the beautiful grand
master shots that feature our heroes and
you can see their entire body the
choreography and it just feels
incredibly epic the lightsaber sequences
in this film have some of the most
beautiful wide shots I have ever seen
it's very apparent how much Ryan Johnson
has been inspired by Japanese films by
samurai films anime it all feels very
much so like the Jedi are almost samurai
and if I'm wrong and that wasn't what he
was going for that's what I saw
and some of the imagery here is gorgeous
the action sequences are some of my
favorite that I've seen in a Star Wars
movie they're really really good
Adam driver as kylo Ren continues to be
very compelling a terrific performance
he and force awakens I thought was a
very conflicted and deep character not
your average villain he wasn't done yet
he wasn't fully trained he wasn't ready
he had angry deep-seated emotion that
really shone through in his work and he
is amazing here and this film continues
to deepen kylo ren's legacy in ways that
I cannot wait to talk about in the
spoiler review really satisfied with
everything they did in this movie with
every major character Oscar Isaac is
once again amazing as PO such a likable
presence let's talk about Finn and Rose
because this leads me into my issues
with the last Jedi there's a storyline
here that involves these characters Finn
and Rose that feels like an extended
short film almost like the movie just
stops and becomes something else
something else I didn't really enjoy all
that much it's a sequence on another
world that feels almost too much like
Earth this place they go just did not
feel like a galaxy far far away it felt
like a place you might see here on earth
just with a few more exotic creatures
but it wasn't just the setting it was
the fact that it basically screeched the
story to a halt and every time it cut
back to them I was like okay is this
gonna get more interesting here is this
gonna get better
reminded me of in the Phantom Menace
documentary when George Lucas had just
seen The Phantom Menace for the first
time and you see him sitting there in
the theater agonizing over the fact that
he can't remove anything because it all
connects and he's just kind of like oh
boy well Rick what do we do I can't
really remove any of that stuff because
they're all kind of you know interweaves
oh boy
you know a special effect without a
story is a pretty boring thing Rick you
know oh boy
Jar Jar is the key to all of this jokes
aside this sequence with Finn and Rose
it's just too far along and the things
that they have to do sure it effects the
plot later but they're just should have
been an easier and quicker way to do
some of these things because it feels
like a detour an unnecessary detour it
reminded me of in Avengers age of Ultron
when Thor goes off looking for that pool
you're just like what all right
unfortunately this sequence is necessary
to set up some things that you're
supposed to care about later and I just
didn't we'll talk more about that in the
spoiler review but that is my one major
issue with the last Jedi that 20 to 30
minutes that are combined this Finn
storyline now obviously it's not just a
30 minute chunk of the movie it's spread
out over the film but it's one of those
things like I said where you're going
back to this place and you're like yeah
this could be better
pushing all that aside I honestly love
the last Jedi I had a really great time
with this movie I think it has some of
the best action sequences in the entire
saga it has some of the best
performances in the entire saga it has a
compelling and conflicted villain and it
has tons of surprises there are a lot of
things that happen I did not expect I'm
not the type of person who likes to go
in speculating though so that could be
different for you I don't like to sit
here and make up theories and guess and
try to predict things I like to go in
just like I can't wait to experience
this I also like John Williams score
this time around more than I did for the
force awakens his music of course is
always going to be really good but his
score for the force away
was one of my least favorites it just
felt a little rushed this one feels
better it's like he had more time let's
talk about porks real quick they're
adorable
they're amazing and they're not annoying
thank God
captain tarpals never forget
bb-8 once again has a lot of moments to
shine Chewie
does as well as does the Millennium
Falcon some really awesome Millennium
Falcon sequences I honestly love this
film I don't know about where it stands
for me but the force awakens I want to
see it again let me see it this Thursday
we'll do a spoiler review after that I
think I'll be able to give you my
official ranking of where this fits in
but it is a damn good Star Wars movie
there are a lot of emotional moments
that I am looking forward to talking to
you more about in the spoiler review if
this review seems a little vague it's
because I feel like that's what you
would prefer we'll talk more about that
after the film is released but rest
assured this movie made me really happy
I'm gonna give the last Jedi and a -
definitely better than rogue one I had
characters that I actually cared about a
story that felt like it was beginning
middle and end made by one person it
didn't feel like an assembly line
product it didn't feel like another
movie we've already seen it's
structurally its own thing sure there
are a few little beats here and there
where you might be like I've seen that
before I've seen that before but this is
definitely made by somebody with a
unique voice Rian Johnson and I think he
did a damn good job I'm looking forward
to seeing it again I can't wait for you
guys to see it thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get steppen
eyes
[Music]